Here I introduce to you to a web page rendered by the web browser
we'll have built by the end of the class.
In this problem, we asked you to generate the HTML that creates this page.
A skill in becoming a computer scientist and a programer
is the ability to look up information on your own.
We ask you to look up a few of the tags that are used here
and figure out how they apply in order to generate this page.
I will briefly go over the tags that are used to generate various parts of the page,
and then I'll quickly show you the HTML as a finished product.
Every web page begins with and ends with HTML tags.
To use the level 1 heading, we had H1 tags.
We created paragraphs using the P tag and we had two paragraphs.
We created this unordered list--unordered because each item in the list
is just a bullet and not a number using the UL tag.
Each item in the list begins with an LI tag--standing for list item.
Within the list item, we can have another list, in this case it's an ordered list,
which is define using the OL tag--standing for ordered list.
In each item, like in the unordered list is defined with an LI tag.
And now we have most of the structure for these webpage, I want to go back
and highlight a few instances of tags that change how the page looks.
For bold, we use B tags, for italics we use I,
and there is also small and big tags that change how large or small the font size is.
We can change how the font looks with TT tags.
One last thing to note for changing how the text looks
is the strong and emphasized tag elements.
We use the strong instead of the bold when we want to describe the meaning of the text
oppose to the formatting of the text.
We went over how hyperlinks works in class but as a reminder
we put the text of the link in between two anchor tags,
and we set the target as the hyperlink reference.
For an image, we use the IMG tag as the source of the image,
as a URL, or relative pass to the image.
In this case, we've defined cs26.png, the same directory as this page is being rendered.
For details like that, we recommend that you check out Steve Hoffman's class cs253.
Now, to look at the finish products, let's go quickly to the ID.
Here I have the finished HTML and it should look strongly similar
to what we worked out together with just the output.
Keep in mind that the HTML that you created can look different in many, many ways
for reasons such as different white space and things like new line spaces, etc.
while the output of the HTML page looks the same.